let's start and thank you very much for
coming
so
my name is Karen
I uh start I'm
developer not data scientist so it's
probably the first first thing to say
and I start as a game developer and then
join startup called T-Mobile work there
for five years then work a little bit at
a palm
with epic games and then joined
streamlit
at previous year and streamlit uh
acquired by snowflake so now I am
software engineers
uh so
yep let's uh let's
uh see who's listening uh so the first
question probably is uh
who used who already used streamlit
okay
so next uh I I hope that after this talk
uh this number probably
increased so uh and uh who is like work
with data every day who is data
scientist let's say in Jupiter notebook
with r or whatever cool yeah so this is
a right place so talk
okay so the story behind streamlit and
by the way streamlit is presented to
White auditory and became
the open source announcements uh was
happened at 2019 at Pi data conference
it was paidata La I guess so I like that
uh
uh like sync and uh so what problem uh
basically we stop like usually the usual
day of uh data scientists like ml
researcher whatever someone who works
with data you probably work in your
Jupiter notebook right and uh
you write something you explore your
data you have some results and then you
need to share that knowledge with
someone with your stakeholders with your
students with your colleagues whoever at
at that point uh
uh it's sometimes the the project just
finished at that point so like okay I do
something in my Jupiter notebook I have
answers for my questions that's it
but more often but more often you have
to prepare something to show let's say
to stakeholders and at that exact point
uh you find yourself with uh writing
some react flash code I don't know fast
API maybe and this is so what's uh the
problem with that in my opinion and once
again I'm not a data science system like
software engineer but uh the state of
mind when you work with data and the set
of mind when you develop just the
application it's a little different
thing so it's difficult to you know
change that context and and
start to think all about HTTP codes
callbacks or whatever so and it's
usually not something you want to do you
uh so but anyway maybe you just learn
how to write some flask code some HTML
maybe JavaScript and then you present
like you create something that you can
then show wrap your model or whatever
but yes then
it's like became unmaintainable because
if you need to add new feature you have
to learn new things and more and more
deep going into like uh
becoming uh like web engineer instead of
being a data scientist
not so good okay sometimes in some big
companies or I don't know there are
special uh teams like two League teams
whom you can ask like hey I have this my
shiny project could you please create uh
application or or
something around that
and uh
that's the case for example I've worked
for uh epic games in exact that two-link
team when they need like not uh for uh
data scientists but for like other
things that they need to automate create
the internal things and it also works
that you have like another team of
weekend engineers and another team of uh
front-end engineers and you just maybe
create your specs and and and give them
uh so book day time and then create for
you your uh application
but it's still a problem because uh at
that time you have dependency from them
and that people they usually are very
very busy and let's say after one month
they go to another project because it's
not you and then you need to change
something to tweak something and you
couldn't do that right so you you still
in that uh on maintainability Hall uh
besides that there often happens when
they're like you know
worse for resources when different
departments Etc so how how great it will
be if you could like uh create that
application and share it with
stakeholders with colleagues and uh like
anyone with whom you want to share like
yourself without uh having to write a
lot of backend code front-end code
and learning all that things and just
working with your data similarly how you
work work in in Jupiter notebook let's
say with the same like
uh mindset
and
Yep this is a bad part and this is yeah
so that's what the main thing the main
problem that we try to solve because uh
sharing your results your data science
work with others is is hard uh sure you
can share your Jupiter notebook but it
means you should share that with someone
who also technical who could install it
who could run it who could have all that
environment in in the notebook and if
it's like just I don't sell company uh
maybe it could be a little bit more
problematic which means then decisions
that probably like should be uh data
driven became intuition driven or you
have to go to through all that layers uh
oh
like adding more and more people manage
them organize them having all that teams
that could prepare something and the
another thing is that uh like feedback
cycle is for uh data heavy apps it's
very short because you create something
and then maybe someone asks you to
change your tweak or add something else
and uh it's very critical that you could
do that yourself without asking other
people or or spending like a lot of
hours and uh
at the internet Googling for answer how
to
upload a image or whatever
yeah so spreading that technology is
hard sharing your work with others is
hard
and getting from data to action is hard
meet streamlit
yep so what is streaming stream it is a
open source library that uh I guess it's
open source for almost three years that
allow you to create that application
that will show demo a little bit later
uh with the same like very simple from
Top uh to down approach when you write
your python script and then magically it
transforms to uh interactive web
applications and you can basically
create anything because you just wrote
your python script it's not you know
some site Constructor with predefined uh
stuff or Builder or whatever you wrote
your python which means yeah no we will
show uh see it's a little bit
later yeah and we have all that uh
widgets and they are interactive so you
can use them and you also can
like use all that Titan ecosystem that
already exists because you just run your
python script and anything could be
imported and brand and whatever
so the bokeh multiple clip tensorflow
like
Honda Senpai whatever yeah so like three
main uh things that we uh the base is
that this is just a python script and uh
we have of course widgets but that we
just you can think about them just about
like variables so you can write x equal
St dot widget
from 0 to 100
and then the FC dot slider and then
slider appears in your site and then you
change your slider value and that exact
value uh there in variable X in your
script
uh and of course uh you can reuse that
and computations will provide you a
caching Primitives so you shouldn't
since we already run your python script
you can just Mark that part for example
loading models it can be just done once
and then you just uh use it so yeah
let's see so this is what I say you can
just uh
import it and write it and this is the
app
or
yeah or you can add some interactivity
with sd.slider and then this how it
works and uh
as I said we have caching Primitives so
if you need to create a to Cache or keep
database a connection you can use it as
Singleton it will not recreate data
based connection each time or if you
have to to
memoize a big chunk of data you also can
use experimental memo and we also have
old sd.cache primitive so and since it
is just a python script you can connect
it or get data from whatever you
whatever you want this is just a
tutorials like how to get data from
public Cloud sheet or from Snowflake or
from mongodb but basically you can do it
with any Source right and yes here we
also allow you to manage your
secrets so if you have secrets let's say
credentials to connect to your database
Etc it's also uh
here we just exit.c that you can access
them and you can store them in separate
files
yes and we have layout Primitives so you
can customize your application with
Customs them
we have a
like set of built-in components but they
are also ability to extend and a lot of
people write their own custom components
and you can use them you can write your
uh component if you need something
custom
so this is like a first part and the
second part will be a demo so do you
have any questions for this party app
I will repeat the question
frankly saying we have some dependencies
and we obviously render uh mark down so
you can in SC dot right you can use
markdown I'm not sure what exact Library
we use for so but can you go back to us
no no different direction I guess
different direction okay
it's like a markdown so St Wright is
just a basic it's like print or a
console log but you also can put
McDonald's
you also can use markdown in estimate
and we correctly parse it and and nice
yeah we will see that in demo uh a
little bit later yeah uh any any other
questions at this point
yep
one thing about this problem case where
um so like this kind of solutions are
more customized right so because you
have the control over what you develop
and what visualizations you can use but
you need to write some code and it's
hard to convince here Enterprise that
actually this is better to use than
Tableau given the cost that it incurs
along with it and so like other than the
cost of time for developing the charts
and everything how would you convince
that well this solution specifically is
more scalable and like Superior to like
commercial products like tableau
so see I guess the Tableau is uh like a
business analytic tool right and and
yeah and uh
I think we have a little bit different
use cases they are overlap a little bit
but here you brought like python code AS
and you create very custom like
basically you can just a little bit
modify your Jupiter notebook and uh have
your uh web application so
imagine like think about stream it I
like that analogy like uh notion for
example we in our company we love notion
and we use it for documents for expects
or whatever so this is a tool that
allows you like effectively collaborate
of course probably it's not a best idea
to develop High load uh site and uh
just use notion for that some people do
that for example but uh it's uh more for
demos for experiments for sharing your
thoughts with with stakeholders uh
non-technical peoples and Tableau I
guess mostly you dare just clicking on
buttons here you write a code but you
write the code in that manner that you
used to write like just simple python
scripting not all that uh
not all that uh specific things that
maybe you're not interested in to know
okay yep
so let's
start
with writing code and
so uh
what we do we allow you to create a
interactive web applications
which means in Jupiter it's more like
your working environment which you just
play with that Etc after you have some
results you should have something with a
flask application right to to have a
side web server so we
uh like uh ask you to write script but
in very simple similar manner uh so I
think we can
one one
okay uh
let me show you
let's create a new project from scratch
I will show you how simple is that and
that's it like live demo
and let's open this
uh Library
oh sorry
we are here this is completely empty
directory
okay
so
let's create a file python I'll call it
up.pi or whatever you want
and
let's create a virtual environment you
can use anything uh dependency
management tool like poetry people I
will use just uh virtual lamps because
it's a simplest thing right
so let's create
virtual environment
activated
and install streamlit
foreign
yeah
that's the dot right
hello board
and
so
you can just say stream that run upper
by dot pi
and we have this application so if I
change something for example add
markdown
so it's changed
and you can easily add interactivity
with like just let's say as I say x
equal S3 dot slider
uh Josh eggs or
X just sticks
or whatever this custom label from zero
to
142 by default
and let's write
uh x square
yeah so we have this slider and if you
change something you can see the the uh
square number here so if you change it
like works so the way how we do that as
I say we just rerun it from top to
bottom which means you can think about
your application as just like normal
python script
okay so let's create something a little
bit more difficult maybe some image
processing up I have prepared up but I
will build it with you and at some point
I just reuse small parts from there
so first of all we need some import
sources and let's say we want to be able
to upload our image like do something
interesting with it and from from camera
from your custom URL or from just file
uploader
so we have that image so let's say we
have want to have image bytes
right and
uh we can create St Dot
file uploader
upload
on the file
so type
PNG or
jpeg
and
as I said here in streamlit widgets are
just variables so you can assign them
the value to variable
so you can say image bytes
equal to
a step file uploader
or let's do a little bit more complex
layout let's say that we want to have a
radio button like
and it can be URL
camera
or file uploader
and let's say
if and
input type
and if input
after you start using copulot you know
it's very difficult
a input type is URL let's just uh render
a
text input so we'll say URL equal s3.
text input
uh
and if URL
so we need also a style requests here
this is a library that allows you to
make the network calls
and we say image but it's equal
probably I need to install it right
so after importing it
I can say
request.geturl dot content
and
a leaf if input type is
let's say camera
so the value of this uh
radio button is just a one of this
option that we provide as a list so next
sense I guess
yeah so if camera let's render
camera input
so if we
and let's assign
image bytes
variable
twitch
and
if
input type is
file uploader
let's just say that
image bytes is equal output of
file uploader so basically this this
line here
uh-huh
and let's
uh
for now just draw this image
so let's see
oh
let me enable I guess yeah
Okay so
no problem
yeah so if image bytes
uh it is not none
let's draw it otherwise
let's show a warning
like please
upload an image
so
now you have this controls right and you
can use URL camera or file uploader
to upload your
image
so we upload it this is
by the way
or you can use
uh your camera to make a selfie
so see this camera
problems or not
render it because Let's see we have
image bytes
yeah so we should say let's say camera
input we could say what camera input
what whatever
selfie with return file like object but
to get bytes you need to say
image bytes is equal selfie Dot
get value I guess
yep
so let's try again
yep now you have it
or five minutes
and the same thing that we did or we
should did like
uh if selfie
is not none
and same thing here like uploaded file
right and
if uploaded file is not none
now it should work okay the good news is
that now you have
you have your image bytes and you can do
with that image by with whatever you
want you can use any like transformation
like pass it to any model or or whatever
and uh
I'm also a little bit more
complex example based on this let's just
hide this part of UI I want to show you
that we have uh
sidebar and
like
easily you can put all these UI into
s10. sidebar
and so now it lives here
so you can
so
yep and this is resizable we add this
feature like literally yesterday at our
Yesterday release
app
and let me show you since I have only
five minutes uh maybe a
yeah a little bit more complex example
of the same
up
so let me stop running it
and now I can
run my
trimmed it up
or
let's use old version for now
um
the same thing stream later on just the
name of
your script and if you look at the
script it says the same thing that we
did it's just uh have all that UI to
upload your image and if it exists
uh we have another models.pi file where
we import models from
Keras so basically just vgg and mobile
net
and we Define uh
functions to load models and put them
under the I need probably like more five
minutes under the experimental single
tone so it will be like each time you do
some interactions we will not reload
your model it's like safely return that
Singleton of that model one for uh vgg
one for mobile net and just organize old
necessary utility things into in that
dictionary like for vgg we have that
model the function uh their own function
for the preprocess and for the code
predictions at the same thing for mobile
net
so here what we did after having that uh
image bytes
we just uh
have another salad box then you can
choose the model
and after that we load that model uh
prepare image with corresponding
function that we use from that
dictionary called predict and receive
predictions data frame uh
uh and uh
draw it basically so let me show
so we need a little bit time yeah so the
same UI that we just like create but now
you can uh
after after
uploading your photo let's see
uh-huh
now you can choose the
uh model because we have two of them and
so
mobile net said that this is more likely
safety and and vgg said that this is a
water bottle so
yeah
means this time but what I try to say
that how easily you can create uh
applications that you can just uh have
more interactive things and even
after that
really you can we also have with uh
one second we can say columns equal St
Dot columns2
and for e
in
uh supported models keys instead of
using uh like
for model name
right
and let's have
a
to iterate over there
and we can say with column this is
another layout primitive
you can render that to uh
model side by side
foreign
and let's remove this thing
yeah
so now after uploading an image you can
uh
uh see the predictions side by side and
this is easy like you just create two
columns and you like you can here create
like let's say left and right column
left and right
uh
probably this will a little bit more
under you can create as many columns as
you want to
yep so
uh yeah that's the that's just a one
example uh
in reality we have
a lot of
widgets so buttons
Primitives for working with Mobs
all type of like date input time input
select boxes multi-select whatever and
they like the killer feature is they can
you just use them and then for that
input use in your python script to uh
pass it to your model your uh
data frame and then render that data
frame with extremely just with one line
yep
uh-huh Yep this is an example the code
will be
in GitHub repo and yeah then we have a
streamlit cloud you can deploy these
things as I said this is a completely
open source so you can deploy it
whatever you want Amazon instance uh
Heroku or but we also provide our Cloud
where you can deploy just with one click
and then we take care for scaling
monitoring and all that things and you
can easily share it uh with with people
uh
yep
uh please check out Gallery where we
have a lot of very different so this is
just example of image like uh
classification but you can organize like
create whatever you want like just go
crazy it can be uh like
uh
everything
as I said I'm software engineer I'm not
that a scientist yep and remember that
this is like you just install it with
people with Peep In Style streamlet you
don't need any other things to get
started
yeah that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
questions
yeah thank you very much this is really
cool and it's gonna make life a lot
easier for a lot of people in uh
especially within the teams I was
wondering if it has an API as well for
not not just like human driven
not for building UI by building
endpoints right
no we're focusing on building UI you can
you can customly like Define your things
but they basically the output is uh
widgets and you can just build your
interactive web application
so if you use uh if you your target is
like building uh API custom apms
probably uh you can use stimulates but
it will have the same amount of
additional work that if you use let's
say fast API or flask or junglers
framework yeah okay thank you yeah
I was wondering like there are several
options from the visualization libraries
to choose from right like well totally
bird altered those Yeah you mentioned I
wonder whether there is one specifically
that has the best integration that works
best with streamlit
so see uh four widgets for outputs we
support like some set of that as you
mentioned you can use Altair charts you
can use Pi deck you can use whatever
that also like that's we like officially
support that's part of a library uh for
example you can call uh
I'm not remember but let's say and
rendered that matplotlib graph on your
site but uh there are also Custom
Companies for example if you you want to
use uh a grid we have uh
custom component that's maintained by
community and there are a lot of people
who use that but everything that we like
use inside streamlit uh we like
officially Support also custom company
this is just a third-party components
you can write your own thing with just a
little bit of HTML and python will allow
you to extend it
but uh yeah uh
difficult for me to say like what we
support best we support like many many
of them but the most important like bulk
HRS or or anything but uh the biggest
Advantage is that so at display part
they are let's say some maybe
limitations but on a processing you can
use anything because this is just on
your python script so you just import
whatever you want and do with your data
also whatever you want so yeah that's
the answer thank you
yes
from the beginning of your presentation
I've got an image that these framework
best suited for
demonstrating the result of data
scientist work for a team let's say for
business users who can play with model
in a native for them waves through UI or
adjust some parameters yes and can uh
see if they if the model might meet
their expectation is it the right vision
of the yeah that's one of main use cases
when you share with stakeholders you
work and allow them to play with that
work that could be not just let's say
like uh prediction models but
visualization of your data will also
support a lot of types of charts like
you can use like any chat Library
any major chart library to just you know
do some visualization or or like for
annotations for whatever you want so
we're not like narrow our use case for
that uh any specific part but basically
you stream it to share your work as a
data scientist with other maybe not so
technical people just to present them an
interactive web applications and the
only your imagination is limit what you
can create with that and how you want to
show it
any other questions
nope
thank you very much